[Music]
in this morning Saturday session Josh
Ritter a musician taste magazine calls
one of the top 100 greatest living
songwriters his works earned him acclaim
from high-profile fans like Stephen King
Cameron Crowe the director and the
Grateful Dead's Bob Weir who co-wrote an
album with him Josh will perform in a
moment but first I talked with him at
his home in Brooklyn New York when did
you start writing songs I was 17 and I
heard Bob Dylan and Johnny Cash and go
from the north country on a record and
and it was the first time I thought this
is a language that I understand this is
something that is for me
[Music]
Josh Ritter was raised in Moscow Idaho
the son of two neuroscientists we grew
up my brother and I around the kitchen
table hearing what were adventure
stories about science but you actually
went to college to study neuroscience I
started yeah yeah then I ran into
organic chemistry and realized that that
dream would have to die I remember
calling my parents and saying I don't
think I'm gonna be a scientist guys I'm
sorry what did they say they said all
along we knew there was no chance
instead he studied the history of
songwriting straight from college to
Providence yes and then moved to
Providence Rhode Island taking jobs in a
landfill and a luggage factory while
playing any open mic night that would
book him
Irish songwriter Glen Hansard caught his
act one night and took him to Dublin
[Music]
we're Ritter found a following in 2003
his album hello Starling hit number 2 on
the Irish charts
[Music]
that must be kind of weird to find your
success in a foreign country at first it
was it was it was funny for so long it
was it felt like it was my secret but
American audiences eventually caught on
to Ritter's writing skills this was the
code we could keep each other warm I
said on the first occasion that a memory
on songs like the temptation of Adams
about a romance in a missile silo the
temptation of Adam came to me at the
beginning as almost like a pickup line
and so I get that if this was the Cold
War we could keep each other warm and
and I started to realize the
implications of that
[Music]
my job as a songwriter is keeping an
aperture open in my brain and letting
things fly through that space can be
pretty intoxicating when you're in there
and it's working yeah it's feels like a
fine kind of gray silt or dust is just
kind of pouring down on me it's
comforting and it's it's kind of
electrifying Ritter's new record is
called gathering this is my album cover
yeah yeah this is it he painted it
himself I thought it was really
beautiful but it had a sense that things
could change to Ritter chose it every
time it rains it pours I pray rain just
a little more um when he realized the
new songs he'd written were like a
series of storms I think oftentimes
writing is excising something it's
taking the things that you that you are
building up in your mind and it's
removing them so that you can like think
about something else for a change
[Laughter]